- No matter who you are, no
matter where you are in life,
you can take the lid off of your job.
There is nothing bigger than your dream.
It's going to take more than
a notion to become successful.
Like I always say, life is
10% what happens to you.
It's 90% what you do about it.
And you got to prep and
plan, and plan, and plan.
Extend yourself beyond your
normal levels of comfort.
And buy your first class ticket.
- Hello, Believe Nation,
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe.
And I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey, today,
we're going to learn from
comedian, TV host and actor,
Steve Harvey, and my take on
his Top 10 rules for Success,
Volume two.
Rule number one is my personal favorite.
And I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're listening,
if something really resonates with you,
if there's a message that
really holds true to you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put it in quotes so that
other people can be inspired.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to stick
with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(powerful music)
- No matter who you are, no
matter where you are in life,
you can take the lid off of your job.
And if you're wondering
if you still have the lid
on in your life, here are some clues
that's going to let you know
that the lid is still on.
If you're not excited about
waking up in the morning,
if you're sitting around
bored out of your mind,
if you've got time to do
everything anybody asks you to do,
(audience laughing)
you probably got the lid on.
If when you tell your
dreams to all your friends
it makes sense to them,
you got your lid on, man.
Your dreams should not
make sense to everybody.
You got to say something
that make people go,
"How you going to do that?'
That's when you got the lid off.
And if I were you, I'd do
that, I'd take the lid off.
Make sense to me, darnit.
(audience laughing)
The one thing that I have learned to relay
to all of my children
is to dream.
There is nothing bigger than your dream.
Nothing is greater than your dream.
Now as we sit in this great
educational institution,
I am not saying that your
education is not important,
because it's tied to a lot of your dreams,
but let me tell you something.
There ain't nothing, nothing,
bigger than your dream,
because your dream will propel
you to get the education.
Don't you ever stop dreaming.
Don't you ever stop imagining.
Oh, we're going to talk
about them two things a lot.
But don't you ever stop dreaming.
Your Bible says a man
without a dream or vision
shall perish.
That's in your Bible.
It ain't just in the one I read.
No where in there does it say
without education you perish.
But it says without a dream
or vision, you perish.
So if what you are dreaming
about requires an education,
it is then your dream that
propels you to get the education.
But the dream is bigger
than everything, man.
See, if it was an education
that caused you to be great or successful.
I ain't here today, 'cause
I don't have one of them.
But nobody could outdream me.
Your dream is everything, man.
It's the biggest part of your life.
(audience laughing)
(laughs) Look man,
it is that thing that God puts in you
that don't let you sleep sometime.
It's your dream.
It's that thing that part of you, man,
that wakes you up and stirs
the very pit of your soul.
I've always taught my children to dream.
The secret, though, the
secret to real success
is if you tie your gift to the dream.
It's going to take more than
a notion to become successful.
'Cause one you get this
degree, it's actually
just going to be a piece of
paper on the paper on the wall.
That's really all it's going to be.
Some people may give you a job with it.
The majority of people going to tell you
how much experience you need.
So you got to hustle, man.
Got to hustle.
Hustle and grind, dig, man.
Got to fight, you've got to
have a lot of dog in you,
man, to be rich.
Now if you just want a job,
get yourself a little job,
create some nice, little
life, get a little house,
some grandkids.
(audience laughing)
(drowned by laughter)
Get yourself a little
minivan, a station wagon,
go on and ride your life out,
ain't nothing wrong with that.
But if you really, really,
really want to be bolder,
change some people's lives,
get yourselves some real money,
hire people.
Get more than one stream
of income coming in,
got to be hustlin', man.
You got to be a hustler.
You all in the tank.
That shit is money, man.
(audience laughing)
Money can't buy you happiness,
they ass don't have no money.
(audience laughing)
Let me tell you what, you go be poets,
see how that work out.
I lived in a car for three years, man.
I struggled.
But I had a dream and a vision.
When I got there, I hustle, man.
I hustle.
Every man in this room, you blew your 20s.
You spent all your 30s tryin'
to make up for your 20s.
- Yep, that's the truth.
- Dog, every dude in
this room blew they 20s
and at 30 tryin' to fix what they
should have did in their 20s.
And so far it's on.
You turn 40, you're trying
to recover from the mistakes
you made when you 30.
Now at 40, man, it's
time for you to start.
Really, at 30 you need to
start bucklin' it on down.
And just realize, man,
everybody make mistakes.
And the mistakes you going through
are going to help you become the person
you need to be later on.
- Steve Harvey.
- All them mistakes,
dog, they cool to make.
I needed to mess up every marriage.
I need to get arrested like I did.
I needed to get shot.
I needed all this, dog.
- You got shot?
- I needed to be home.
Yeah, let's not bring that up.
(host laughing)
Because all them people
that be talkin' about,
"Man, you get shot, it
don't hurt it just burn."
That's a complete lie.
(others laughing)
Pow! (screaming)
Oh, Jesus, Jesus!
(gunshots exploding)
I'm telling you, shot ain't what you want.
- Shot aint cool. (laughs)
- I needed all them things to happen
to turn me into who I am today.
So when you're young
and you make mistakes,
don't let 'em eat you up,
'cause everybody that done
made it done made 'em.
You got to fail in order to win.
Hey, look, man.
To understand how to hit
the game when it's shot,
you got to miss the game when it's shot.
- Steve Harvey (drowned by Steve).
- You gots to miss 'em.
- Well, I'm stuck in a
rut because I can't seem
to follow through with anything.
I went to college for a
year-and-a-half and I dropped out.
Then I went to cosmetology school.
I completed that, but I never
went back to get my license.
Then I was a pharmacy technician.
And I recently let that
license expire as well.
I just see so many people that are my age,
and they're already set in their careers.
And I just feel like at
29, I'm a people person,
so I want to do something
like human resources
and I just need help.
Like where do I begin?
- First of all, you're talking about stuff
that I can relate to, like
so many others can relate to.
I mean, everybody got the same story,
we just got different details.
But like I always say, life
is 10% what happens to you.
It's 90% what you do about it.
See, we're going to dive into
a chapter from my new book.
And it's chapter one, section one.
This is very clear for people.
So the first step is getting
completely and brutally honest
enough to say, "I am tired of myself."
When you say, "I'm sick and
tired of being sick and tired."
That's the facilitator of change.
That's when you're ready
to say these words,
"No more excuses."
No more excuses.
I went to Kent State, I dropped out.
Well, I didn't drop out, I flunked out.
Now that threw my life into a spiral,
but because I didn't
have a college degree,
I could not let that stop me.
And like you're doing,
where you're saying,
"All my friends at this age
are settled in their careers."
You don't even know if
they're happy or not.
Stop comparing yourself to others.
So the first thing you do is
stop focusing on other people.
Instead, focus on being the best version
of you that you can.
Then you'll recognize
that you deserve to sit
at the big table with everybody else
after you become the best that you can be.
Now once you've accepted
that you have as much right
to success and much right
to succeed as anybody else,
the next step is learning
how to talk to talk.
You have to get fluent in
the language of success
so you speak it with ease.
Surround yourself with people
who've accomplished their dreams.
And immerse yourself in
the culture of achievement.
I've learned if you're a farmer
a farmer understands better
than any other worker
in this country.
A farmer has an understanding
that most people never achieve
in their life.
I really respect the farmers
and their commitment.
But I respect also their understanding.
My grandfather and my uncle,
the thing was to wake
up early in the morning,
before you start your
day, you start your day
by feeding all the animals.
I never understood that.
Why am I feeding slop to these hogs?
Bailin' this hay for these cows,
taking food out to the hunting dogs?
Going to get these mules and horses,
walkin' 'em down to water?
Why am I feeding these chickens, man?
All this before I eat?
My grandfather says,
looked down at me, says,
"Young man, if we don't
take care of these animals
"that we are requiring
to take care of us,"
he said, "what's going to happen to us?"
He said, "We're depending on
them chickens to lay eggs,
"to give us meat.
"We're depending on them hogs for meet.
"We're depending on the
mules to pull the plows
"so we can plant.
"We're depending on them horses
"to drag all these wagons around.
"We're dependent on these hunting dogs
"to go out in the wood and
uncover the animals for."
So then what I respect about farmers is
they understand that
everything comes in seasons.
There is a planting season.
And you got to plant, and
plant, and plant, and plant,
plow, till, hoe the rows,
you got to do all that,
seed it, fertilize it, in
order for a crop to grow.
Now here's what happens some years.
Some years it's a drought,
ain't no rain, ain't no crops.
Sometimes it's a flood,
wipe out all the crops,
all the plants.
But, guess what?
You still got to do the planting,
'cause what you're bankin'
on is just enough rain,
just enough sunshine so you can harvest.
And even the crops get washed
out, even if the floods come,
even if the drought come,
the thing about a farmer,
they do it all over again,
because they understand
that eventually you'll be able to harvest.
And that's what I respect about farmers.
And that's my life.
You know, you got to be tough
because the road to success
is always under construction.
It's never a clear path to success.
The people who become successful
are the people who have
a relentless attitude.
And you just got to hang in
there through the bad breaks,
'cause the bad breaks is comin',
but they usually come
right before the big break
is about to happen.
You get a series of bad breaks
and it stumbles up a lot of people.
My life and my success
is to say to anyone,
"You can stumble, you can fall,
you can get back up again."
And like I've said before,
we each have a gift.
But too many people miss
out because they refuse
to sign the lease on their gift.
You keep looking for it outside of you.
Stop. Sit with yourself.
What is it that you do the absolute best
with the least amount of effort?
That's your gift.
But if you are constantly
looking outside of yourself
and you don't latch onto your gift,
you will never find your purpose.
If you want to succeed, you
must commit to your own gift
and embrace it.
Knowledge is necessary to
get you to the next level.
But after you get to the
next level, guess what?
All that's out the window.
Geometry, history, all that's
out the window, man, sorry.
You know?
You got to learn this
and this can only be learned in life, man.
With you all sitting up in
here catching first team
is life lessons that you
could use when you're 58.
You understand?
You ain't going to, you
just can't get this,
it's not available.
You got to see it.
So what you're actually doing is...
See the thing about knowledge, man,
you can Google knowledge.
You could go online and
get knowledge on anything.
You could press a button
and read about this
and read about that.
And you can go and repeat that.
And people go, "Wow, he's knowledge."
Okay, cool.
But exposure, exposure
is totally different.
Exposure is when you see it,
touch it, feel it, go there,
experience.
That's different.
Exposure, once you open
your mind to exposure
you can never shrink your mind back down.
'Cause exposure don't decrease.
Once you've been exposed and your mind
expands from exposure, you
can't shrink it back down
and act like it's okay.
See, once you fly in first class,
you can't walk past there
without feeling some kind of way
and watch them people shut that curtain.
You can't.
'Cause the whole time you back there,
see when I flew coach,
man, everywhere I went,
'cause that's what I could afford to do.
When the plane take off and
they close that curtain,
the whole time I was wondering,
what are they doing on the
other side of that curtain?
Well, they're denying the exposure,
because they can't show you.
They can't show you watching them people
get a whole can of coke.
They can't show you that
they get their nuts warmed up
in a container.
They can't show you that
they give all them people
a hot scented towel to
freshen their face and hands.
They can't show that to you,
'cause you didn't pay for that.
See, you bought the coach ticket.
So they closed the curtain.
They don't even let you come up there
and use their bathroom,
because they just need to
keep these 10 seats available
for those people that pay.
That's what the curtains do.
'Cause they know if they expose you to it,
then you're going to want it.
"Hey, I want a whole can of coke."
"Well, we can't do that, you didn't pay."
Or "I want some hot peanuts."
No, no, no, no, no.
Now on the airplanes, you got to pay.
Now they done figured it out,
you got to pay for the sandwich.
You got to pay for the meal now.
You get a choice, but
you get to buy it now.
It's crazy.
Your first class ticket
gets you a free food,
gets you more than one bowl of nuts.
You can get free drinks up there.
You don't pay for beer
and drinks in first class.
It comes with the cost of the ticket.
So once you sit in first class
and you open your mind and
expose your mind to it,
see, bruh, you can't go
sit in coach no more,
'cause you've been exposed.
But if you keep walking past first class
and let 'em close the curtain
and never get the experience,
you can grow your whole
life thinking coach is fine
But mess around and buy
yourself a first class ticket.
You will forever be changed.
And you will never forget
what first class was like.
But that's the beauty of exposure.
It makes you aim and perform
towards the exposure now.
So that's why Dick Gregory said
you should always, whenever
you can go first class,
extend yourself beyond your
normal levels of comfort,
and buy your first class ticket.
Get you a first class
suit, get you a first class
pair of shoes.
'Cause once you put it on,
you understand what they're charging.
And now you are forever changed,
because through exposure your
mind cannot shrink back down.
Knowledge, you can forget
when Christopher discovered America.
You can forget that equation for gravity.
You can forget MC squared,
you can forget that.
You can forget what's the pi root theory.
You could forget the square root of 181.
You can forget the square
root of 81, that's knowledge.
- Come on, now, that's--
- That's the back?
- Yeah, that's the back.
(audience laughing)
- There you go.
(audience applauding)
You look good, man.
Does look pretty good.
(audience laughing)
No, you look pretty good.
- I like that.
- You like that.
That's a pretty good look.
I got that.
I got this, too, in case,
'cause this is the next step.
If you don't do the green
juice, you end up with that
if you don't do the green juice.
And then--
(audience laughing)
It's going, it's goin' on there.
- That's what I'm talking
about, and we're back.
(audience cheering and applauding)
We're back with Steve Harvey, everybody.
He's talking about his new book.
Steve, you had a great year.
- We ain't going to talk about
a damn thing when we come back.
Get your ass out the way!
(audience laughing)
- Hey, hey, old Steve Harvey, calm down.
Can I get you anything?
Can we get you a juice or anything?
- I don't want no damn juice,
I want to ham sandwich.
(audience laughing)
I want to ham sandwich
and two white girls.
(audience laughing)
- No, hey.
No, hey.
(audience laughing)
Old Steve Harvey.
- Thank you, guys, so much for watching.
I really hope you enjoyed this video.
If there's someone
you'd like me to profile
in the next Top 10, check out
the link in the description
and go and cast your vote.
I'd also love to know what
was your favorite message
from this video?
What did you learn from this video
that you're going to
immediately apply somehow
in your life or in your business?
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Cyrus Webb.
Cyrus, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and posting it
to LinkedIn with your review.
I really, really,
appreciate the support, man.
And I'm so glad you enjoyed the book.
So thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- I have a lot of people who (mumbles).
To be honest with you, I'm very fortunate
in that I love what I do.
So when I'm hosting Family
Feud, I'm on every day.
I'm on a talk show every day.
I got a live radio show,
four hours every day.
I love what I do.
And I use humor to keep
me alive and young.
I'm 58, but I act like I'm eight.
(audience laughing)
And I just keep laughing, man.
(audience applauding)
You ever notice people don't
laugh why they look older?
- [Audience] Yeah.
- Man, just start laughing
at some of these guys.
We're goin' over here, look
at all this (bleeping).
(audience laughing)
Life is really 10% what happens to you
and 90% what you do about it.
Look, everybody in this
room, everybody watching,
everybody got something
they got to deal with.
Get to dealing with it.
Stop complaining about it.
Complaining about it only
makes it stay present.
Do something about it.
(audience chattering in agreement)
So life is 10% what happens to you,
it's 90% what you do about it.
Don't you know that however your life is,
that it can be even more wonderful
than it really it?
And young people, do you
know that whatever you write
that's what you're going to be?
I was showing somebody
my telephones, my iPhone.
I got two iPhones.
You cut 'em on, you cut my
iPad on, you cut my laptop on,
you cut every desktop I
got in every office I got.
The same vision board pop up.
Oprah said, "I didn't know
you had a vision board."
"You got one!"
(audience laughing)
If Oprah got a vision board,
why ain't I going to have no vision board?
What I'm crazy?
I've been studying successful
people for a long time.
The all do the same thing.
They all got visions and dreams and goals.
They're all written down somewhere.
They all wake up excited about their life.
They all run out of hours in the day
because they just can't get it all done.
And they can't wait for tomorrow.
Now if your life ain't like that
it's 'cause you aint' living
your life in the fullest, man.
Now who problem is that?